i've decided to sign for one more year
on the show and that this will be
this will be my last year hosting the
late nation
don't you dare
and there'll be there's there'll be
tears
there'll be so many tears um
because this has been the hardest
decision i've ever had to make it really
has james corden near tears telling his
audience that he'll soon exit the late
late show never taken this job for
granted ever not once and if you
the fact that you watch us at home or
you watch us online wherever you are all
over the world the fact that we get to
try and entertain you and spend time
with you
is an absolute privilege for me and
every single person who makes this show
as the late night host addresses his
exit in his monologue on thursday he
also explains the reason for his
decision when i started this journey
it was always going to be just that it
was going to be a journey an adventure i
i never saw it as my
final destination you know and i
i never want this show to overstay its
welcome in any way i always want to love
making it and uh
i really think in a year from now
that would be a good time to to move on
and and see what else might be out there
okay i don't think that the show was
ever going to work
so
it is quite surprising when you start to
look back and think about all of the
things that we've
done on the show gordon first signed a
contract to host the late late show in
2014 and made his debut in march 2015.
hello everyone i know what you're
thinking you're like oh look andy
richter's got his own show
welcome to the late late show everybody
and following the news of his impending
exit the source tells et the court's
choice didn't exactly come as a surprise
quote i think we all could tell he was
ready to go the late late show crew has
been waiting since january for james
corden to re-sign his contract before it
was up by the summer time some of the
crew already had a feeling gordon was
not going to re-sign so they started
looking elsewhere for work opportunities
the source adds that while the exact
reason for gordon's departure is unknown
there has been some buzz about him
wanting to spend more time with his
family last december when e.t caught up
with him ahead of his 1000th episode he
echoed a similar sentiment it will
always be a bigger family decision than
just whether i want to
continue hosting the show and stuff you
know we we have
my wife and i we have you know
grandchildren that are a long way from
grandparents we have brothers and
sisters that that we're a long way from
and
and
you know look this was always an
adventure
for me and and my family rather than a
destination so
i don't know how long we'll do i've
loved every second of doing it i
certainly have never ever wanted to
overstay my welcome i've never wanted it
to be
something i consider a job i've never
wanted it to be something that i
don't get excited to to wake up in the
morning and go and do now one thing is
for sure gordon is ready to go out with
a bang we're not leaving today we still
have a year to go and i am we are all
determined to make this the best year we
have ever had making this show we are
going to go out with a bang there's
going to be carpools and crosswalks and
sketches
and other surprises please for the next
12 months it is going to be a blast i
promise you that
you